Were there any lectures or lectures
series that you found helpful to you,
this Nathan,
like yours have been to so many?
Well,
Nathan,
you know,
okay.
I would say not really.
Um,
although,
you know,
when I went,
I went to this little college called
Grand Prairie Regional College.
It was a way the hell
up in northern Alberta.
And um,
yeah,
there's only 600 people that went,
it was an adjunct of the
University of Alberta.
It's still exists.
It's really lovely building.
Um,
and we had professors there.
Okay.
An English professor and the political
science professor in biology,
professor philosophy professor,
people that I still remember
little seminars and they,
we got deeply into the
material and I really,
it really helped me a lot.
This English professor really taught me
to write to because he just slashed my
essays to ribbons.
I was really upset the first time I got
a bad grade because I'd always got good
grades and my papers in high school,
even though they were dreadful.
Um,
you know,
I was verbally intelligent enough to be
able to compose an essay that was better
than most with very little effort
and with very little quality.
And so that was very influential to me
and I did a lot of reading under the
tutelage of those professors in these
tiny little courses in my first year.
But mostly what's been
helpful to me have been books.
And you know,
I read Nietzsche,
I didn't read all of nature,
but I would read all that was easily,
easily accessible,
published works of nature in sequential
order in the order in which they were
written when I was in my twenties and I
read everything that young had published
it when I was in my twenties and um,
and well,
and the same with a wide
variety of other authors.
And so those were like
lecture series and they were,
I was unbelievably useful to me.
I put some of those
books on my reading this.
So,
um,
could you please tell us your second ghost
story as mentioned on h three h three
podcast.
God,
Nicholas,
if you asked me that at the next
Q and a and people voted up,
then I'll tell the story,
but I can't right now cause it's a
long story and I'm just about out of
[inaudible] and brain and time.
And that's,
so I'm going to answer two
more questions I think,
and then I'm going to stop because
I really am running out of,
um,
words.
Let's see.